veamos si podemos evaluar la integral
indefinida de x sobre 2 que multiplica a
seno de 2x cu + 2 dx ponle pausa al
video e intenta hacerlo por tu cuenta
veamos qué tenemos aquí tenemos x sobre
2 que está multiplicando al seno de 2x
cu + 2 si solo tuviéramos que calcular
la integral de seno de X
dx pues esto es inmediato pues sabemos
que la derivada con respecto a x de
coseno de X es igual a - seno de X Así
es que si nosotros derivamos - coseno de
X su derivada va a ser + seno de X Así
es que este integral es igual a - coseno
de x o para que quede más claro pongo un
signo menos aquí y un signo menos acá y
aquí claramente tenemos la antiderivada
de os seno de X que es coseno de x y con
este signo menos - coseno de X Pero eso
no es lo que tengo aquí no tengo seno de
X tengo seno de 2x cu + 2 pero aquí
tengo esto acá que tiene x y lo que
podrías estar pensando aquí Bueno cuando
tengas la suficiente práctica vas a
estar pensando así es que esto es
interesante esto se parece a la derivada
de esto de acá si esto lo llamamos no ya
me cansó este naranja vamos a agarrar
otro color si esto e Qué pasa aquí a ver
qué pasa con los colores Ahora sí si
esto lo llamamos fdx
si FX es = a
2x + 2 entonces la derivada de F con
respecto a x F prima x es igual a
4x pero aquí tenemos x sobre 2 qué tal
si multiplicamos por algo afuera y
adentro el integral para obtener
4x lo primero que necesitamos Entonces
es multiplicar el integrando por 4 para
que tengamos 4x aquí y para que no se
altere la integral multiplicamos por
fuera por 1/4 También tenemos este dos
que está dividiendo que nos está
estorbando vamos a sacarlo al integral
vamos a multiplicar por fuera por 1/2 de
tal manera que esto lo podemos escribir
como 1/2 * 1/4 es 1 oav que multiplica a
la integral
indefinida de
4x seno de 2x cu + 2
d x y aquí ya se está poniendo buena la
cosa pues si te fijas esto de aquí
déjame hacerlo con el color adecuado
esto de aquí es F dex seno de F dex
mientras que esto de aquí es F prima de
X es decir si observas bien esto ya
podemos aplicar aquí la regla de
sustitución con lo cual Esto va a ser
igual a no déjame usar el color adecuado
esto es igual a No aún no tengo un nuevo
paquete de arte que aún no entiendo lo
de los colores esto es igual a 1 octav
que multiplica a la integral de F prima
de X La integral déjame usar el color
adecuado la integral de F prima de x y
esto multiplicado por
seno seno de F dex dx necesito meter
seno de X dentro del paréntesis
seno de FX dx Entonces cuando lo
escribimos de esta manera nos damos
cuenta que excelente podemos aplicar la
regla de sustitución tengo el seno de la
función y tengo la derivada de esa
función Así es que puedo obtener la
antiderivada del seno con respecto a esa
función básicamente lo que estamos
haciendo es sustitución u si esta de
aquí es u Entonces 4x dx es deu pero
aquí estamos agarrando práctica para
hacer este proceso mentalmente Entonces
a qué va a ser igual este integral esto
es igual
1 de Ya vimos que la antiderivada de
seno de X va a ser menos coseno de X Así
es que la antiderivada de Esto va a ser
menos coseno de FX Así es que esto es
igual a 1 octavo que multiplica a menos
coseno de
fdx menos coseno de fdx ya esto por
supuesto tenemos que sumarle no mejor
cierro este paréntesis en azul a esto
tenemos que sumarle la constante de
integración c y ahora para obtener el
resultado de la integral original en vez
de FX vamos a ponerlo en términos de X
es decir sustituimos FX por 2x cu + 2
Así es que esto es igual a un octav que
multiplica a tengo una función y tengo
su derivada por lo que integro con
respecto a esa función para obtener un
octavo que multiplica a menos coseno de
FX que es 2x cu + 2 2x cu + 2 y eso más
nuevamente problemas con el cambio de
color y eso má c puedo sacar el signo
menos del paréntesis para obtener - 1/8
del coseno de 2x cu + 2 + c y así hemos
concluido hemos usado la regla de
sustitución podríamos haber utilizado la
sustitución u pero lo que hemos querido
practicar es que si ves una función y
ves su derivada entonces puedes integrar
con respecto a esa función que es la que
está serías como u Pues aquí también
tienes duu esto de aquí por esto de acá
es duu así es que estamos integrando
seno de u deu te invito a que lo hagas
resuelve este problema por sustitución u
y vas a verificar que obtienes el mismo
resultado